l es jeunes dévoués et bûcheuse sa
passion les animaux
à 26 ans mylène bégin et la
copropriétaire de la ferme de production
laitière prennent si l'entreprise de son
arrière-grand-père ici si toute sa vie
j'avais 6 ans tu as tellement petit
fallait que je grimpe sur le bord de la
buvette à l'eau franck avant d'accrocher
la première nil nbi lycées sont quinze
bêtes et connaît par coeur le nom de
chacune d'entre elles elle publie
régulièrement sur instagram
son but démystifier l'image négative qui
circulent de son industrie elle est
maintenant suivie par plus de 14 mille
abonnés aujourd'hui est de plus en plus
de projets comme des couacs et on met
nos animaux nos animaux sont riches puis
je reçois des commentaires de tous les
styles pour moi c'est important de
montrer quel point que de démystifier
ces mauvaise image mais son initiative a
tourné au cauchemar
you are just un élément l'exploitant les
vignes reçoit des centaines de messages
de groupes militants vegan extrémistes
d'un peu partout dans le monde
l'accusant d'abuser de ses bêtes de les
torturer et vont même jusqu'à la traiter
de viol 2 c'est depuis environ un an que
des producteurs québécois comme il n des
jeunes reçoivent des messages haineux et
des menaces un phénomène qui était très
très importants dans d'autres pays à
travers le monde
mais cette année on entend beaucoup plus
se parler des répercussions que sa loge
chez les produits par le véganisme est
un mode de vue ses adeptes ne consomme
aucun produit animal et refusent
d'acheter tout produit issu des animaux
comme les vêtements et les cosmétiques
il n a rien contre les vegan mais
déplorent ce qu'ils font du prosélytisme
et qui sont extrémistes ce que je suis
quand c'est le véganisme extrémistes qui
voit jusqu'à l'harcèlement pierrette
desrosiers dénonce ce qu'elle considère
de la désinformation de la part des
extrémistes qui font circuler des vidéos
de ferme qui sont des exceptions à la
règle souvent giro j'ai jadis on
ramassait les 10 pires minutes des
paires par an au québec qui commettait
ce boutabout sur youtube en chine je
pense qu'on va trés poster réalisé tout
le monde mais les gens ont un gros bon
sens qui disent ça représente pas c'est
quoi les parents au québec certains
messages envoyés à mylène proviennent
d'un groupe de militants en equateur
l'une de ses membres qui n'est pas
l'auteur des messages a bien voulu nous
parler quand elle restera les malaises
qui selon emeline mansur le fait
d'éliminer artificiellement les vaches
pour qu'elle soit enceinte et ceux à
répétition dans le but de les garder en
état d' alerte mans constants
c'est un geste très violent bien plus
violent que la prose des militants
baisse est important d'informer les gens
pour que les gens ouvrez les yeux et se
rend compte de la violence normaliser et
de laquelle sont victimes la plupart
d'animaux au monde c'est à dire les
animaux qui sont exploitées de façon non
nécessaires pour la consommation des
soies des viandes ou d'autres produits
animaux elle croit que la science a
démontré que les protéines animales ne
sont pas indispensables à la santé donc
que rien ne justifie l'existence en 2019
des fermes de production laitière ou de
viande
pierrette desrosiers trouve que ces
militants cellulaire à la main
manque de cohérence quand j'ai lu
l'arrière du cobalt à l'intérieur on
sait que des enfants qui travaillent
dans des mines de cobalt
alors avant de traiter nos agriculteurs
de tous les maux il faudrait être
capable de s'examiner dans nos propres
pratiques et dans nos propres
incohérences
pour mylène dénoncé de la violence en
utilisant de la cyber intimidation
ça n'a aucun sens par mesure de
précaution pour la santé de ces animaux
mais aussi pour sa sécurité
mylène afin d'installer des caméras de
surveillance mais c'est violent c'est ça
qui est par moments j'ai peur j'ai pas
pour ma sécurité puis j'en dors mal
j'ai pas qu'il se passe quelque chose un
pendant la nuit s'il la sûreté du québec
assure garder un oeil sur les messages
que je reçois mylène la psychologue créé
un sérieux dérapages qu'à l'école qu'est
ce qui va arriver quand on va demander à
un jeune
qu'est-ce qui fait toi de ton père et ta
mère dans la vie qui veut dire bon mois
mais perrin sont producteurs de lait aux
producteurs de porc comme ça ce sont des
violeurs et des toiles est ce qu'on ne
pense c'est un pas clos c'est pas banal
alors que les producteurs vivent déjà
des pressions énormes pour assurer la
survie de leur entreprise
ce genre de comportement pourrait
décourager la relève
ils n'ont j'ai tellement la passion
animal que je l'aurais jamais mon métier
mais pas mylène